[Musique]
c'est une petite gaffe qui se présente
comme ça où il ya juste un qr code qui
est imprimé dessus de manière à ce que
les policiers qui interviennent au
domicile des victimes d'éventuelles
victimes puissent présenter puisse
donner discrètement surtout cette petite
carte portait la victime lorsque les
policiers quittent le domicile soit avec
l'individu si l'auteur des faits s'est
vu interpellation soit si les parties
soient enfin peu importe pour que la
victime donc qu savoir toutes les
coordonnées nécessaires à son
accompagnement sans même des soins
d'accompagnement en forme nos collègues
à l'accueil
et puis à la prise en charge dont
notamment leur explique ce qu'est
l'emprise mentale le stress post
traumatique qu une victime n'est pas
forcément comme on pourrait l'imaginer
mais il me manquait un petit un petit
maillon dans la chaîne c'est-à-dire que
quand les policiers interviennent au
domicile jeux vidéo ont parce que j'en
fais partie on est sûrs en les seuls à
pouvoir entrer au domicile quand la
famille est recluse noué entre
guillemets séquestrés ou contre udine
d'ailleurs patron par son conjoint et on
est les seuls à avoir ce contact là avec
la victime dans un premier temps on a
mis les appels en cas d'urgence le 17
le fait d'aller déposer plainte
le fait qu'ils aient plateforme à
disposition des victimes et ensuite on a
mis des contacts plus locaux propres
yvelines avec cinq associations des
yvelines qui sont clairement nommés
clairement ciblé et qui peuvent être
contactés par la victime
[Musique]
ça peut permettre de libérer la parole
donc si c'est une voisine par exemple
qui dénonce ça peut nous permettre
d'ouvrir une enquête
alors évidemment l enquête n'est pas
d'initiative des policiers il faut
qu'elle soit comment on pourrait dire a
dicté par la justice entre guillemets
mais ça peut permettre de prendre des
contacts et puis d'aller d'aller au
contact de la victime qui osera prête
pas faire par cession
on arrive à toucher une ou deux victimes
et qu on la sauve entre guillemets ben
on aura déjà fait notre travail